des images du capitole qui rappelle
cette journée du 6 janvier dernier une
manifestation de soutien à donald trump
prévue aujourd'hui on rejoindra notre
correspondant à washington pour faire le
point sur l'atmosphère et le dispositif
de sécurité vous l'imaginez très
important sur place
[Musique]
10e femme dit de manifestation des anti
pas sanitaire dans toute la france où
180 rassemblements étaient prévus on a
manifesté à toulouse à lille notamment à
paris trois manifestations distinctes
dont une des gilets jaunes l'un
en algérie des préparatifs étaient en
cours aux alentours du palais du peuple
au dans le centre de la capitale alger
pour accueillir la dépouille d'abdelaziz
bouteflika décédé hier soir à 84 ans
mais rien d'officiel encore sur la date
et le lieu à des funérailles dans la rue
on va le voir dans ce journal le respect
devise l'axé président algérien a dirigé
le pays de 1999 à 2010
buté face à la pression populaire
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france et on part
tout de suite du côté de washington
souvenez vous le 6 janvier dernier le
capitole pris d'assaut par des pros
trump et bien ce samedi le revoici au
capitole placée sous très haute sécurité
nouvelle fois par crainte des
débordements on retrouve sur place
thomas bonne escient
bonsoir à thomas quelle est l'atmosphère
au lancement de la manifestation
eh bien écoutez je peux vous dire que la
manifestation est quasiment terminée la
foule s'est dispersée il était peut-être
100 voire 200 au plus fort de cette
manifestation
ils sont donc venus demander justice
pour les personnes qui ont été arrêtées
lors des événements du 6 janvier dernier
au capitole il estime que beaucoup ont
été arrêtés alors qu'ils n'ont pas
réellement commis de violence qu'ils ont
simplement assister à cette
manifestation
je vous propose d'écouter les
témoignages que nous avons pu recueillir
ici tout à l'heure
les gens ont fait irruption dans le
capital parce qu'il voulait renverser
une élection démocratique dans laquelle
ils pensaient avoir été trompé nous
avons donc un terrain d'entente je suis
du côté démocratique du spectre
électorale je suis aussi pour la
construction d'une unité et d'une
démocratie forte donc je suis très
heureux qu'ils disent aussi vouloir une
démocratie forte et transparente parce
que c'est ce dont nous avons besoin
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour moi
que la réforme électorale soit le
problème de droits civiques qui
connaissent une attention grandissante
aujourd'hui dans le pays
c'était important pour moi de venir
aujourd'hui car plus de 600000
américains ont été inculpés dans les
événements du 6 janvier des dizaines
d'entre eux sont toujours enfermés et la
façon dont ils sont traités est un
scandale les personnes qui n'ont pas été
incriminés sont retenus sans raison ils
sont isolées jusqu'à 23 heures par jour
est la seule façon pour eux de parler à
leurs avocats ou de recevoir des visites
c'est via zoulou par téléphone ils sont
soumis à des conditions vraiment injuste
beaucoup de gens avaient peur c'était
une tactique d'intimidation
on leur a dit que c'était un piège que
s'il venait il allait être arrêté et les
gens ont peur des services de police du
fbi et du ministère américain de la
justice
entendu ce dernier manifestant tenté
d'expliquer pourquoi cette manifestation
n'avait pas rassemblé beaucoup de monde
il faut dire que même le président
l'ancien président donald trump avait
pris ses distances avec ce rassemblement
rassemblement qui s'est déroulé sous
haute sécurité un dispositif policier
très important qui est en partie levé à
l'heure où je vous parle il reste encore
des forces de l'ordre qui sont toujours
déployés le but était d'éviter
évidemment tout débordement toute
dégradation toute violence est
évidemment l'atmosphère était
particulièrement paisible aujourd'hui il
n'y a donc eu aucun débordement a
dénombré merci beaucoup thomas bonnet
pour toutes ces précisions vous suivez
donc pour nous cette manifestation qui
touche à sa fin au capitole
en france 10e samedi consécutive de
manifestations contre le pass sanitaire
une journée de mobilisation dans un
contexte tendu c'est mercredi dernier
que l'obligation d'actionnaires est
entrée en vigueur et cette mesure elle
passe très mal les soignants l'acompte
est dans la rue à des rassemblements
donc aujourd'hui partout dans l'hexagone
à toulouse lille notamment et à paris
trois points de ralliement dont un des
gilles et jo l'on fait le point avec
notre reporter estelle fâche
c'est aux cris de macron ton patron ne
veut pas que les gilets jaunes ont
déambulé dans les rues de la capitale ce
samedi le retrait du pass sanitaires et
la fin de l'état d'urgence c'était les
principaux mots d'ordre de cette
mobilisation est des mesures qu'ils
considèrent comme elle liberticide à
l'image et danic et de jean-françois que
nous avons croisé au pour eux cette
mesure est non seulement liberticide
mais elle est aussi illogique je vous
propose de les écouter je suis contre
l'instauration du pass sanitaires
je trouve que c'est une mesure policière
qui n'a aucune justification sanitaire
précisément tout ça ça crée un climat
d'acceptation d'un niveau de contrôle
par des biais diverses qui a un climat
extrêmement
extrêmement inquiétant quoi cette
impasse politique
on peut pas
voyager sans pas sanitaires un avion
dans les tgv mais on paie sainte assez
tranquillement dans le métro
qu'est ce qui lie à saint littéralement
c'est un choix politique et sociale
on peut rentrer dans un super marché
bondé mais on peut parler dans une
bibliothèque programme bouquin je me
suis entendue dire tu m'as vu dans une
bibliothèque où je voulais aller prendre
de legear qu'il fallait que je fasse un
test comme j'ai décidé de ne pas me
laisser c'est une question de confiance
moi j'veux pas confiance dans les
épidémiologistes qui prétendent nous
gouverner et qui décident sur notre tête
ce qui est bon et ce qui est pas bon
pour nous au-delà des mesures sanitaires
avec lesquels ils ne sont pas d'accord
il y avait aussi en toile de fond à de
cette mobilisation les toutes premières
revendications du mouvement des gilet
jaune à savoir plus de justice sociale
et plus de justice fiscale et nous
étions avec laurent alexandre essayiste
et chirurgiens et rémi tales cofondateur
du collectif pas plus libre je vous
propose d les écouter chez
la situation est en train de s'améliorer
ce qu'on voit c'est une diminution très
importante de la mobilisation il ya
chaque samedi de moins en moins de monde
et il y a de plus en plus de gens
vaccinés on vient de dépasser 50
millions donc en réalité on est en phase
d'amélioration sanitaire on espère qu'il
n'y aura pas d'aggravation avec
l'arrivée du froid en octobre mais même
s'il y a une vague le niveau de
protection qu'on a avec le vaccin
devrait éviter qu'on ait beaucoup de
morts puisque les toutes dernières
études montrent que le vaccin diminue
par 11 le risque de mourir du cosy de
toutes classes d'âge confondues laurent
alexandre avec lequel notion d vacants à
peu près surtout a au moins le mérite
d'aller jusqu'au bout de ce qu'est le
communisme dans son organisme son
racisme social son cynisme absolu
jusqu'au refus de traiter les personnes
malades laurent alexandre luneau
caractéristique c'est de s'être aussi
trompé sur à peu près tous depuis début
de cette crise et notamment sur la
vaccination massive évidemment je ne
rejoins pas son point de vue sur les
effets supposés bénéfiques de la
vaccination ce qu'on voit c'est que dans
les pays où vous avez une vaccination
massive en israël par exemple la
situation est aujourd'hui catastrophique
autre manifestation aujourd'hui à paris
en ligne de mire cette fois les lieux
d'accueil pour les consommateurs de
crack en réponse à un courrier d'anne
hidalgo de la fin du mois d'août le
premier ministre jean castex a donné
mercredi son feu vert à l'aménagement de
ces nouveaux sites on écoute à ces
réactions de manifestons aujourd'hui
devant la mairie du 20e arrondissement
alors moi je fais bien la part des
choses aujourd'hui le crack c'est un
problème circonscrit à certains quartier
du xviiie du 19e et du 10e ya aucun
problème de crack dans le 20e
mais on veut surtout pas que ça arrive
chez nous donc c'est pour ça qu'on
s'oppose fermement à l'ouverture d'une
salle pour prise en charge de ces
consommateurs chez nous nous nous sommes
aperçus que les élus ont tendance à
essayer de mettre des salles dans des
zones où il ya beaucoup d'enfants il ya
beaucoup de populations et la difficulté
c'est que les rapports le rapport de la
commission des affaires sociales et le
rapport de l'inserm précisé que de toute
façon il faut essayer d'éviter de mettre
ces
salles de soins de soute quelle qu'elle
soit de manière un peu plus enfin
qu'elle soit moins à proximité de la de
la population et notamment des écoles
que ce n'est pas possible mais le
premier ministre qui souhaite poursuivre
le déploiement du plan crack signé en
2019 entre l'état et la ville mais
évidemment cela ne plaît pas à tous les
parisiens ont fait le point avec katia
technique et grégoire douce et
des consommateurs sous l'emprise de
l'addiction des habitants excédés le
fléau du crack est toujours bien présent
en france et notamment dans la capitale
ici on a par exemple un exemple typique
de cracker qui fument en fait en plein
milieu de la rue parce que on a beau
nous dire qu'en fait c'est interdit et
c'est vrai que ils se disent ils peuvent
faire ce qu'ils veulent dans certains
quartiers comme ici dans le 19e
arrondissement est la présence des
consommateurs fait grimper le sentiment
d'insécurité nombreux sont les riverains
à se sentir désarmé on essaye d'appeler
la police a vient pas on essaie de
contacter la mairie tout ça ils font
rien on sait plus comment comment
interagir avec eux donc on appelle les
journalistes on essaye de faire des
vidéos de faire du bruit quoi pour qu'on
nous laisse pas comme ça parce que parce
qu'on n'en peut plus tout simplement il
faut vraiment arrive à soigner ces gens
là il faut qu'on puisse vivre dans un
atmosphère sereine riverains c'est très
difficile très très dur en sait plus
comment et qu'est ce qu'on doit faire il
ya quelques jours il ya une quinzaine
d'avions et un viol juste en face
d'abord vous voyez une situation qui
pousse certaines personnes au
déménagement ancienne résidente du
quartier juliette a pris la décision de
partir moi j'ai habité dans l'immeuble
au wild aubervilliers pendant 25 ans
c'était infernal les toxicos on ouvrait
la porte pour descendre pour aller
prendre l'ascenseur pour aller
travailler le matin on les pousse est du
côté des usagers tomber dans l'addiction
peut aller très vite pour ce
consommateur que nous appellerons didier
paris représente une tentation trop
forte qu'il faut fuir à tout prix pour
se sortir de cette spirale infernale
[Musique]
ouais répartir pouvoir à plus de 100
kilomètres de pavés
cccc mieux à faire je la garde d'être
venu ici il vous ment pas c'est mon pire
cauchemar si paris a savais pas que ça
allait à l'espace à en croire les
chiffres de l'association gaïa il
existerait près de 5000 fumeurs de crack
rien que dans le nord-est de la capitale
est toujours sur le front des
manifestations des milliers de chasseurs
ont battu le pavé dans plusieurs villes
amiens orléans caen ou encore
mont-de-marsan colère à la suite de la
décision du conseil d'état qui juge à
certaines pratiques de captures
illégales alors que l'ouverture de la
chasse a lieu aujourd'hui les détails
avec un métier ski fis
[Applaudissements]
ils défendent corps et âme leurs
techniques de chasse traditionnelle et
défilent aujourd'hui pour s'opposer à
l'avis du conseil d'état plus de 13
mille chasseurs présents à mont de
marsan d'après la préfecture des landes
pour prévenir les débordements
la vente d'alcool et le transport de
carburant sur l'itinéraire de la
manifestation sont interdits c'est le
socle de bien vivre ensemble la ruralité
elles existent n'y a pas que les grandes
villes et on est régulièrement attaqué
sur nos traditions hier c'était la
corrida c'était les langues régionales
aujourd'hui c'est la chasse demain ce
sera ppl vaches le gavage et tout ça ça
fait partie de ce que les anciens nous
ont transmis ses skis aussi nos loisirs
nos patients et il est hors de question
de se laisser malmener comme c'est le
cas par des lobbys puissants mais qui ne
représente pas cette ruralité qui
s'exprime ici massivement c'était
rassemblant qui montre que nous existons
et qui je l'espère va inverser un petit
peu le logiciel au plus haut niveau ou
pour respecter nos traditions des
rassemblements dans toute la france
l'occasion pour certains candidats à
l'élection présidentielle de lancer leur
campagne jean lassalle à mont-de-marsan
xavier bertrand amiens la ruralité on la
respecte les ruraux les respecte cette
manifestation aujourd'hui et des
chasseurs oui c'est vrai et les pêcheurs
et des agriculteurs
mais c'est tout simplement des ruraux
qui ne disent pas aux urbains comment il
doit vivre mais qui veulent tout
simplement qu'on ne leur dicte pas leur
conduite et qu'on leur laisse vivre les
traditions leurs patients parce que ce
sont des écologistes de bon sens la
biodiversité la préserve depuis bien
longtemps ils n'ont pas de leçons à
recevoir douze mille manifestants
étaient mobilisés selon la police dans
l'ancien fief électoral de barbara
pompidou la ministre de la transition
écologique pointé du doigt par les
chasseurs qui réclament sa démission
un lieu symbolique donc dans lequel les
principaux intéressés défendre leur
cause on a un gros gros ras-le-bol
au niveau de la pression écolo au près
au niveau de pression et colonne on va
dire écologistes purement est durement
punitive
nous
plus que ras-le-bol qui nous laisse
vivre quoi un mouvement d'envergure l'un
des plus importants chez les chasseurs
depuis 1989 une colère profonde exprimé
par une partie du monde rural qui estime
donc injuste les mesures prises à son
encontre
justement des manifestations de
chasseurs que déplore un marine calmer
les militants écologistes présidente de
l'association oil légale en écoute
personnellement je travaille des peuples
autochtones en guyane française e on
peut parler de chasse alimentaire parce
que le prochain super marché il est à
trois jours de pirogue là excusez moi
mais ça vraiment rien à voir en plus il
faut bien voir que la sociologie des
chasseurs en france sont majoritairement
des professions des cadres et des
libéraux et en plus de ça une grande
partie d'entre eux sont des urbains donc
franchement là on est plutôt en fait
dans un espèce de complaisance on essaie
d'entretenir un mythe aujourd'hui du bon
chasseur la vérité c'est qu'il ya des
pratiques de chasse aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne sont pas sélectifs qu'on peut même
pas comparer à la chasse puisque en fait
c'est juste un loisir chassé à la glu ou
tendre des filets aujourd'hui
malheureusement il ya vraiment une
remise en question à avoir de ces
pratiques de chasse de la manière dont
on pratique c'est cette activité sur le
territoire parce qu'on met en danger la
biodiversité la protection de nos
écosystèmes et ça c'est intolérable
la plus grosse rupture du siècle elle
passa très mal au plus haut niveau le
contrat sur la vente de sous-marins
français que l'australie a rompu au
bénéfice des états unis et du royaume
uni une perte de 56 milliards d'euros
pour la france d'ailleurs jean yves le
drian doit s'exprimer ce soir chez nos
confrères de tf1 les ministres des
affaires étrangères qui a rappelé hier
ses ambassadeurs à washington et
canberra pour consultations ont fait le
point avec un grégoire douchy
une image inédite
l'ambassadeur français en australie
quittent le pays c'est à contrecoeur que
jean pierre thébault a plié bagages ce
samedi matin déplorant les événements de
ces derniers jours
il ya tant de choses que nous faisons
tant de projets que nous menons je suis
toujours confiant dans la coopération
franco australienne et australo
française je pense que cela a été une
énorme erreur une très très mauvaise
gestion du partenariat parce que ce
n'était pas un contrat c'était un
partenariat un partenariat qui était
censé être basée sur la confiance la
compréhension mutuelle est aussi un
partenariat basés vous savez sur la
sincérité
une décision historique à la teneur
exceptionnelle annoncée par le ministre
des affaires étrangères français jean
yves le drian sur décision
présidentielle ce sont les ambassadeurs
français à washington et canberra que
paris rappel pour consultation
cette décision exceptionnelle est
justifiée par la gravité exceptionnelle
des annonces effectuées le 15 septembre
par l'australie et les etats-unis
l'abandon du projet de sous marins de
classe océanique qui lie l australie à
la france depuis 2016 hélas non un
nouveau partenariat avec les états unis
visant à lancer des études sur une
possible future coopération sur des sous
marins à propulsion nucléaire
constituent des comportements
inacceptables entre alliés et
partenaires dont les conséquences
touchent à la conception même que nous
nous faisons de nos alliances de nos
partenariats et de l'importance de
l'inde au pacifique pour l'europe une
prise de position regrettait par la
maison blanche qui assure toutefois
vouloir rapidement apaiser les tensions
nous avons été en contact étroit avec
nos partenaires français à propos de
leur décision de rappeler l'ambassadeur
à paris pour consultations
nous regrettons qu'ils aient franchi ce
pas toutefois nous resterons engagés
dans les jours à venir pour résoudre nos
différends comme nous l'avons fait à
d'autres moments de notre longue
alliance
hasard du calendrier les chefs des
diplomaties française et américaine se
retrouveront la semaine prochaine à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu une
occasion d'aborder ensemble leurs
dissensions en 2016 la france avait
signé un contrat en or massif avec
l'australie 56 milliards d'euros en
échange de 12 sous marin à propulsion
diesel un accord aux enjeux économiques
et stratégiques majeures mais le contrat
du siècle tel qu'il est souvent évoquée
a été brutalement rompue par canberra
mercredi au même moment washington
annoncer un large partenariat de
sécurité avec l'australie et le royaume
uni dans l'inde au pacifique un
véritable coup dans le dos selon les
termes de jean yves le drian et l'
amorce d'une crise diplomatique des plus
inattendus
on va écouter à didier adès trop molle
et ancien ambassadeur à de france
rappelle que la france n'est pas une
grande puissance mondiale écoutez son
analyse
on restera une puissance du clairet
nucléaire on restera bande de concept de
vérité on pèsera ce affaires du monde
des certains monde en afrique et
peut-être au moyen orient met dans le
pacifique on proposera de moins en moins
devant cette alliance entre australie
etats unis et grande bretagne pour on
est on est en 1 1 un politique un à
militer 1a stratégique dans le pacifier
l'est la france doit mettre à jour ou
l'autre que nous sommes tu es une
puissance moyenne est plus une des
grandes puissances qui est à qui ont
existé surtout après après la guerre de
voilà donc on attend la réaction de jean
yves le drian chez nos confrères de
france 2 et non pas tf1 les réactions
maintenant en algérie après la mort
d'abdelaziz bouteflika hier soir les
algériens se montrent dans l'ensemble
respectueux envers l'ancien président
qui a dirigé le pays de 1999 à 2019 il a
quitté le pouvoir sous la pression de la
rue et vivait depuis plus de deux ans
dans sa résidence médicalisée à l'ouest
d'alger ont écouté ses réactions à sa
mort
il était reçu dans n'importe quel pays
dans le monde
le pays s'est améliorée quand bouteflika
est devenu président
le seul problème c'était sa maladie
sinon ça aurait été mieux elle reste
président
ça m'a vraiment fait de la peine
il était très âgé
que dieu ait son âme
[Musique]
nous avons bon coeur nous ne pouvons pas
dire du mal des morts
ils gouvernaient le pays et le protège
et c'est ce qui peut nous émouvoir
[Musique]
il a apporté du positif pour le reste on
sait pas on ne sait pas ce qui s'est
passé
on ne dis pas du mal des morts tout ce
qu'on peut dire que dieu ait son âme
[Musique]
abdelaziz bouteflika a quitté le pouvoir
sous la pression de la rue et du irak
après sa chute pourtant le mouvement de
contestation il fait poursuivi allez
précision avec sébastien a pas
jamais un président algérien n'aura
régné aussi longtemps le 2 avril 2019
abdelaziz bouteflika quitte le pouvoir
après quatre mandats successifs sous la
pression de la population le mouvement
de contestation
le irak remporte un succès historique
nous avons renversé bouteflika mais
maintenant c'est tout le gouvernement
qui doit partir
pourtant celui que les algériens
surnommé boutef accès de pouvoir comme
un sauveur en 1999 dans un pays meurtri
par une décennie de guerre civile
o le peuple
loupé
massivement au
choisi la vie médiocre qui est la sienne
et moi je sais très bien vivre chez moi
s'ensuivirent des élections remportées
avec 80 % des voix en 2004 2009 et 2014
il maintient l'algérie sur le devant de
la scène internationale son costume
trois pièces devient iconique lors de
ses déplacements diplomatiques
mais dès son troisième mandat il y
critique est considéré par certains
comme une marionnette de l'armée grâce à
laquelle il aurait accédé au pouvoir
la lassitude des algériens ne fait que
croître notamment face à la flambée des
prix celui du carburant ainsi que
vis-à-vis de son état de santé qui n'a
fait que décliner après son avc l'ancien
diplomate aux yeux clairs par est
mutique paralysé la perspective d'un
cinquième mandat pousse les algériens à
descendre dans la rue c'est la fin d'un
règne de presque 20 ans
pour camille sari hauteur de l'algérie
histoire secrète d'un naufrage annoncé
aux éditions l'harmattan abdelaziz
bouteflika laisse derrière lui une image
de président contesté écoutez son
analyse
la base bouteflika était tourné depuis
son limogeage seont puis dire par
l'armée et
personne ne s'attend à ce qu'il y ait
des réactions
de soutien ou de contestation on se
rappelle de sa phrase
je ne serai pas président aux trois
quarts je serai président de pleins
pouvoirs mais les incidents de santé
soit cette
hémorragie cérébrale ou ensuite sa
maladie prolongé en fait que le
président bouteflika n'a pas eu le temps
que tu est d'achever cette cette
séparation entre le pouvoir militaire et
le pouvoir présidentiel civile qui
l'attend cros
en termine avec le remaniement
ministériel en argentine une annonce du
président alberto fernandez pour sortir
de la crise politique une situation
provoquée notamment par les mauvais
résultats de son camp aux législatives
marion cotables
une annonce après une semaine de crise
pour l'exécutif argentin un affrontement
ouvert avec la vice présidente cristina
kirchner a poussé le président à
remanier son gouvernement
dimanche dernier les mauvais résultats
électoraux ont créé des tensions au sein
du gouvernement
la coalition au pouvoir frente des todos
le front universelle en français n'a
obtenu que 31% des voix au niveau
national
le système des primaires général pour
tout parti politique
le même jour et à échelle nationale a
été créée en 2009 cette particularité
argentine constitue un baromètre
politique grandeur nature avant un
scrutin
dans la perspective des élections
législatives du 14 novembre prochain
alberto fernandez craint donc de perdre
sa majorité au sénat alors qu'il lui
reste encore deux ans de mandat
la vice présidente s'est elle exprimée
dans une lettre ouverte cristina
kirchner il critique un pouvoir qui se
cramponne à son fauteuil
croyez-vous sérieusement qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire après une telle défaite de
présenter publiquement des démissions et
de voir les responsables faciliter la
réorganisation du gouvernement par le
président
par la suite le ministre de l'intérieur
et quatre autres membres du gouvernement
ont présenté leur démission ces derniers
sont tous considérés comme des proches
de la vice présidente
le président n'a pas accepté ces départs
la ministre démissionnaire reste
finalement à leur poste
par ailleurs le gouverneur de la
province de tucumán juan mansour a été
nommé chef du conseil des ministres la
ministre de la sécurité de l'élevage de
l'éducation des sciences et des
technologies ou également été renouvelée
des mesures pour juguler crise
économique et politique
le pays connaît l'un des taux
d'inflation les plus élevés au monde
jeudi dernier les argentins ont battu le
pavé dans la capitale pour réclamer de
meilleures conditions de vie et c'est la
fin de cette édition merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver dans
une trentaine de minutes reste avec nous
sur rtl france
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la communication des manuels mapon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
pickton et